[Musica]
buon pomeriggio
devo subito dirvi che a me piace
soprattutto ascoltare le storie perché
mi arricchiscono
stasera invece ve ne racconto una molto
breve e mi piace raccontarla perché non
riguarda solamente la mia persona
riguarda un gruppo di persone
il racconto è da sempre lo strumento
attraverso il quale noi trasmettiamo le
nostre esperienze i nostri valori la
nostra cultura e pensando al futuro
della cultura
non possiamo non parlare anche di
bambini bambini che saranno i
protagonisti in quale modo questi
bambini declineranno la cultura io non
lo so io parlo di quello che è il mio
tempo
io sono qui per caso una sera in
libreria
ero stato invitato per la presentazione
di un libro di una mia amica gabriella
genisi io arrivo tutto trafelato in
ritardo e mi scuso con gabriella detto
guarda gabriella mi dispiace stasera
erano in otto e mezza abbiamo appena
finito di leggere in ambulatorio sogno
di una notte di mezza estate che
gabriella li guarda e dice tu leggi
shakespeare ai bambini
ho detto non devi essere così colpite da
questo perché cosa c'è il sogno di una
notte di mezza estate che non sia una
fiaba ai dei folletti birichini a dei
boschi incantati del re e della regina
e che dire del quando abbiamo letto
romeo e giulietta questo amore
contrastato in cui il padre decide del
destino di un proprio figlio ascoltare
ma kill che a sei anni e mezzo di
alzarsi e dire
mio padre non farebbe mai una cosa del
genere mi ama e io lo dico e se lo
facesse lei dice troverai sempre il modo
di incontrare il mio amico magari
durante la ricreazione
nel bagno e come vedete qui io gli dico
continuo da incalzo gli chiedo e le se
tuo padre venisse a saperlo quali sono
le conseguenze
non ti preoccupare c'è mamma fra noi
femmine
ci si intende capite bene cosa c'è in
questa in queste risposte c'è un
ragionamento un'analisi c'è la voglia di
trovare una soluzione e valutare delle
conseguenze è una bambina che ragiona e
quando matilde mi ha detto questo io ho
pensato alle sorelle bucci che sono
sopravvissuti ad auschwitz e che
rispondendo una domanda perché questo è
accaduto
loro hanno semplicemente detto perché
non si pensava più avevano smesso di
pensare con la propria testa
certo noi partiamo nella lettura dei
classici da testi che vengono un po
adattati ai bambini però danno
precedente dico a gabriella abbiamo
fatto la divina commedia non ci
piacevano i testi per bambini della
divina commedia
abbiamo preso la divina commedia abbiamo
tradotto prima a noi stessi dai grandi e
abbiamo cercato di coinvolgere questi
bambini nella stesura di una
sceneggiatura nella riscrittura della
divina commedia è veramente bello vedere
samira che è la la lonza la lussuria che
si avvicina a michelangelo e gli dice
guarda come sono bella tocca il mio pelo
morbido e tu rinunci a me e alle mie
belle amiche solo per beatrice
l'organizzazione mondiale della sanità
dice la salute non è solo assenza di
malattia organica
non è che se non ti funziona il fegato o
se ti funziona il fegato o il rennes e
tu sai bene e anche salute psicologica e
possibilmente anche realizzazione
sociale
molti non sanno che la stessa
autorizzazione mondiale della sanità
dice il singolo atto che maggiormente
può influire sulla crescita di un
bambino è la lettura e io sono uomo e
sono anche medico
voi pensate che l'accesso alla cultura
sia facile per in età pediatrica
non lo è non lo è perché ci sono tanti
ostacoli in italia ci sono secondo
alcune indagini il 50 per cento delle
famiglie di bambini in età scolare da
sia dieci anni ha in casa solamente
libri scolastici e nel 25 per cento dei
casi i bambini leggono solo testi
scolastici
dobbiamo rimuovere questi ostacoli la
letteratura medica ci dice anche che
dobbiamo intervenire presto dobbiamo
intervenire presto perché che vi
piacciono
oggi si sa che il destino di ciascuno di
nuovo di noi in comincia e finisce tra
virgolette nei primi tre anni di vita
per motivi neurobiologici anche che non
sto certamente a dire quindi noi
dobbiamo investire nel futuro della
cultura investire nella capacità
cognitive di questi bambini è nel loro
sapere dobbiamo renderli anche
attraverso queste azioni indipendenti
nel giudizio solo essendo indipendenti
nel giudizio
loro possono essere creativi e solo se
sono creativi possono darci molto
ora io non ho fatto altro si può andare
oltre una semplice sensibilizzazione a
questo tema
voi sapete che c'è in italia un progetto
nati per legge
beh che si richiama un progetto
statunitense degli anni 80
beh io credo di sì c'è la possibilità di
usare il libro come strumento di lavoro
di salute si perché utilizziamo questi
testi ad esempio per fare educazione
sanitaria in maniera divertente in
coinvolgendo sia i genitori sia i
bambini e posso farlo attraverso le
letture parlare contemporaneamente a 15
genitori non è non è mi fa guadagnare
anche molto tempo e anche i bambini
quando si interrogano in cominciano a
capire che il loro pensiero non è
l'unico si devono confrontare con altri
pensieri
magari alla fine di questo confronto le
loro idee saranno corroborate magari no
ma il rispetto per il pensiero degli
altri e anche per la diversità vi cito
solo un testo si chiama nei panni di zap
questo l'ho presentato a un corso di
aggiornamento dove si parlava della
disforia di genere bambini e bambine che
sono in un corpo che non sentono loro e
ma sono pose rare sono cose frequenti
perché in ambulatorio arrivano mamme che
sono preoccupate un papa che sono
preoccupate perché il loro bambino vuole
giocare con la collana della mamma a
mettersi i tacchi della mamma attraverso
questo libro in cui c'è la principessa
sul pisello che si è scocciata di fare
la principessa vuole giocare a pallone
set up che dice dammi i tuoi vestiti
perché io voglio fare la principessa non
c'è niente di strano in questo invece di
dirlo con paroloni lo si dice guarda
tutti noi attraversiamo questi momenti è
una ricerca di identità anche sessuale
che viene anche prima della cosiddetta
ricerca di chi sono dell'adolescente
possiamo trattare questi temi in maniera
veramente tranquilla in maniera più
rilassata e ricordo le parole di lucia
letto lucia io so che bambina di 7 anni
io so che ti piace giocare a pallone
se ti dicessero che non puoi giocare più
a pallone non se ne pensa nemmeno
dice lucia e se insistessero buco il
pallone così non gioca più nessuno
andrea invece dice io non riesco a
capire come un bambino possa giocare con
delle bambole ma se non mi impongono di
fare questo che facciano quello che
credano quindi non ci saranno modelli
non ci saranno costrizioni che
impediranno un bambino di essere quello
che è
e loro accettano una realtà una
possibile realtà di fronte alla quale
loro possono trovarsi conoscendo noi non
facciamo una valutazione etica di quello
che presentiamo una realtà i bambini e
come in una fiaba il cui bambino ti
chiede tante volte di rileggerla perché
lui è dentro quella storia quando
cammina nel bosco e quando lo vuole
ripercorrere quel bosco per non avere
più paura del lupo
beh la risposta dei genitori è stata
dapprima timida ma poi hanno capito sono
stati anche loro a vuole portare questa
questa esperienza fuori dal mio
ambulatorio e siamo arrivati a
costituire una associazione per la
promozione culturale e civile dei
bambini della quale fanno parte 100
persone e siccome noi siamo persone
concrete
abbiamo deciso anche considerando che
pochi almeno nella mia realtà un 7 per
cento di bambini abitualmente vengono
portati in biblioteca per tanti motivi
abbiamo deciso di aprire una nostra
biblioteca 450 volumi che non sono pochi
e che saranno aperti
a tutti non solo ai miei pazienti prima
di venire qua
giuseppe mi ha detto guarda visto che
vai a parlare di noi non ci fa fare
brutte figure
io gli ho detto non ti preoccupare o il
discorso scritto sul palmo della mia
mano e lui mi dice ma questo è rubare è
un bambino di 4 anni non uso il termine
barare e io gli rispondo
ne riparleremo quando magari leggerai
macchiavelli grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]